- Woonie, Clash of Clans,
the horse's name was Friday.
What?
(jazz music)
What horse bruh?
Hey guys, back at it again,
reading and responding
to your YouTube comments.
What songs are on your workout playlist
and two how often do you have a cheat day
where you eat whatever?
I love EDM, I grew up on EDM,
listening to Tiesto back in the day,
so anything that has a
high rhythm, fast paced.
I'm one of those people that listens
to just about anything if it sounds good,
I know that's kind of a cop out
of an answer, but it's true.
Cheat day, how often
do I have a cheat day?
I tend to use the idea
that you should constantly
be eating healthy
and then occasionally
indulge in sweets and cheats
and all that, so I don't
have like a schedule
where okay, Sunday is my cheat day.
I'm surprised that you said you box.
Are you concerned about CTE?
Great question, traumatic encephalopathy
is a real issue, you see
what's going of in the NFL,
a lot of.
Now that being said, do we
have a perfect understanding
of CTE by any means?
The answer is really no.
I've been to sports medicine conferences
where pathologists have
talked about the damage
that we label CTE on
autopsies being prevalent
in those who have never
played contact sports,
but we obviously know
that hitting your head,
getting concussions over and
over again is not healthy.
I do something known as body
sparring, which is you have
a helmet on, but you're not going
for the other person's face,
so you're only hitting
each other's bodies.
Yes, you can get hurt, but
you're not gonna be hitting
each other's heads so you
don't need to worry about CTE.
Hey doc, what does a nude
person on strike wear?
What does a nude person on strike wear?
I don't know, is this a trick question,
what is this?
Nude person on strike wear?
Nude person on strike.
Yingzhou Lian, please explain to me
what does a nude person on strike wear.
Can you make a video on how to get rid
of water retention?
Thanks, love you and your videos,
thank you JuliaBoo, I appreciate it.
I think that very commonly,
people will overeat salty foods
without even knowing it,
they'll say I don't
even add salt to my food
so how can I be over consuming salt?
And in reality what happens
is people eat very salty foods
like Chinese food is very salty,
Chipotle, sorry Chipotle, it's very salty.
When you eat you know,
three, four, five meals
that are high in salt,
you're gonna have more salt
and your body is gonna have
more water retention.
If you're having severe water retention,
you should go get a check up
with your doctor and figure out
why it is that you're retaining water.
Stay active, sleep seven
to nine hours a week,
a day, imagine if you slept
seven to nine hours a week,
you'd be a vampire.
Seven to nine hours a
night and eat healthy,
not too much Sodium.
Doesn't mean don't eat
Sodium, but not too much.
Yoga by DD, do you do yoga?
I have done yoga, I wanna do more yoga.
I've done bikram yoga,
but I wanna try vinyasa
and all those other forms.
If you're in the New York City area
and you own a yoga studio,
I'm down to come by and check it out.
Reptilian Overlord Jason Blaha,
could be the best
username I've ever heard.
Doctor Mike, how much protein
is required to build muscle?
In reality, the RDA,
which is the recommended dietary allowance
is basically 50 grams of protein per day,
that's what the percentages that you see
on nutrition facts represent.
If you're trying to build muscle
and you're exercising very heavily,
people sometimes think they're
exercising very heavily
when they're really not, so they're trying
to up their protein thinking
that's gonna help them
build muscle more readily,
I don't like to overdo it
when it comes to those things.
I've seen the recommendation
of one gram of protein
per kilogram in your body
and I think that's a fairly safe way
of increasing your protein
intake from the RDA
if you're training to build more muscle.
How many days a week do you
go to the gym doctor Micky?
My name is not doctor Micky.
Clemente I go to the gym
about three four times a week.
Lately I haven't been
weight training as much,
I've been doing more cardio,
cause I've been wantin to play sports,
I've been playing a lot of indoor soccer
and playing basketball,
which I still count as
really good exercise,
you don't have to always
be weight training,
but research has shown
that a combination of
cardio and weight training
is usually the best for our health,
so I'm gonna keep doing both.
Michael Bystrik do a video on
grooming your hair everywhere.
Is it grooming your hair
everywhere on your body
or grooming your hair everywhere
like doing it in the cab,
on the couch, in the bathroom?
I think I know what you mean.
I will do a grooming routine very soon,
I promise, you have my word.
What internet resources can I trust
for medical information?
I really love familydoctor.org,
I think it gives a lot of
broad health information
that is easy to understand,
it's written in common English,
it doesn't have complicated medical terms
that may not mean a lot to you
if you're not in the scientific field.
If you're a medical student
I would recommend using up to date.
Privet doctor Mike,
which means hi in Russian,
I worry for you as you appear too perfect.
Casper I promise you I'm not perfect,
I have weaknesses, I mess up,
the difference between I think myself
and someone who's unhappy is
that I'm generally more okay with failure,
I'm generally more okay with feeling sad,
because I think it's a part of life.
I view stress as my friend
and I use every failure
as a learning opportunity.
So I think that when you
set those types of goals
for yourself, you're
generally a happier person,
but by no means am I perfect,
I'm very messy when it comes
to taking care of my house
and my organization skills
are (makes farting noise)
but I'm learning, I'm trying
to get better every day
and that's what makes it
fun, so enjoy the ride.
Rayyan Paigir, why are some periods heavy
and some light?
Are you qualified to answer that?
Do you have to be a different
type of doctor to do so?
No you don't have to be a
different type of doctor,
I'm a family medicine physician,
so I do gynecologic care,
I do obstetric care,
I do pap smears, just so
you're aware like the type
of practice that a family physician does.
Women's periods, dimension
of cycle in general varies
first of all woman to woman
and it varies month to month based
on a multitude of factors,
diet, exercise, stress levels,
hormonal changes, sleep changes,
even environment changes,
all of those things
play a role in deciding
on how regular your period is gonna be,
how heavy your period is gonna be
so it's important that
when you go see your doctor
and you say hey I've had,
I've experienced a change
in my menstrual cycle,
you give all those details
to the doctor so then we can figure out
and piece together a possible cause
or multiple causes and
then use some testing
and some physical exam
signs to rule them out.
Candy pop love, he said vasovagal response
and I heard it ways of bagel response,
I'm just so stupid.
No you're not, you're
actually really funny
and that's one of your strengths.
What is your opinion on
cosmetic plastic surgery?
Lauren, I know some people aren't happy
with the appearance that they're born with
and it's totally understandable,
I'm not like totally against it,
I think there are instances
where people get addicted to it
and I think that plastic
surgeons could do a better job
of screening this out.
I'm not saying they have to be diagnosed
with body dysmorphia disorder,
it's just some people you can tell
they've gotten too much plastic surgery
and I think that's when plastic surgeons
should step in and be honest and open
with their patients
and think about their
patient's health more
than the health of their wallet.
That's me being a little preachy,
but if whatever procedure you wanna have
is important to you
and it's causing, the disfigurement
or whatever you're upset about
is causing you significant distress
then you weigh the harms of that distress
versus the possible harms of that surgery
and the benefits of
removing those feelings
and you make a decision
that's a personalized one
for yourself.
Remember, plastic surgery
is also pretty expensive
and not covered by insurance.
Thomas Tom, repetitive.
Explain how zombie
apocalypse could happen.
Tom, this is my worst nightmare.
Actually it's my second worst nightmare.
My first worst nightmare is nuclear war,
which I have dreams about all the time,
but the second worst nightmare
is a zombie apocalypse.
It can happen like this.
There's a scientist somewhere in Siberia,
I don't know why I said Siberia,
that's kinda messed up
against Russian people,
considering I'm Russian, but.
So there's a scientist
working in a desolate place
and he's working with all
these different viruses
that can mutate and we
don't have an answer for
that aren't able to be
killed by traditional means
like alcohol, sanitizers, heat even
and it basically makes
people into zombies.
Like they're not necessarily dead,
but it makes them that
they turn into cannibals
and they wanna eat each other and go crazy
I hope it doesn't happen,
but it can happen.
I'm just saying, it
can happen, Thomas Tom.
Or really if we spend
enough time on social media
we'll all turn into zombies.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(jazz music)